don't be fooled by the serene beauty a
new study suggests the ice sheets of
greenland could hold the seeds of a
crisis
researchers say melting ice here will
inevitably lead to major rises in sea
levels
the inevitability is is that the ice
sheet
has to
retreat by the area of a you know a
medium-sized european country more than
for example the area of denmark and
thereby contributes
27 centimeters to global sea level rise
that's irreversible that's committed
the research suggests that global
warming to date will cause a minimum sea
level rise of 27 centimeters from
greenland's ice alone that's a result of
110 trillion tons of melted ice
regardless of any future climate action
taken
where still if greenland's ice begins to
melt at the record rate seen in 2012
those sea levels could rise to a
staggering 78 centimeters
it might take a hundred years but
melting ice poses a direct threat to
low-lying communities in places like
bangladesh runaway melting could spell
disaster the syrian refugee crisis
displaced four million people half of
which tried to enter europe and and you
know we know what the consequences of
that was multiply that by i don't know
100
and you know think about the potential
consequences
the ice is melting some of it beyond our
control
but the rate at which it melts and by
how much
is ours to influence
if we choose to heed the warnings
matthew thompson sky news